mir nun zugeschaltet der ehemalige
radprofi marcel wüst guten morgen herr
wüst sagen sie mir was geht in ihnen vor
wenn sie diese bilder sehen
na ja mir ist ja vor 20 jahren endlich
ist wieder fahren auch in die
absperrgitter knallt bei einem ja das
zeigt mir vor allen dingen das ist sport
auch sehr schnell vorbei sein kann und
dass die gefahr immer mitfährt dass man
da eventuell doch was gegen tun könnte
das ist auch ganz klar und da haben sie
sich auch schon laute stimmen gemeldet
dass es vielleicht mal an der zeit wäre
auch vom weltverband und veranstaltern
einige dinge noch einmal nachhaltig zu
ändern
die teams gerade erwähnt sie mussten
nach ihrem unfall ihre karriere beenden
natürlich weiß jeder der radsport ist
ein extremsport und ist gefährlich aber
was könnte man tun um die fahrer doch
noch sicherer zu machen um ihnen die
angst vielleicht etwas zu nehmen
ich glaube angst hat man sowieso nicht
die wird dann so ein bisschen nach
hinten gedrängt aber wenn man ja auf den
bildern die niedrig diese absperrgitter
sind dass der vario darüber fliegen kann
das ist eigentlich ist eigentlich ein
unding
natürlich ohne regen die fahnen linie
verlassen und dadurch den sturz erst
rotiert
aber grundsätzlich sind wir
beispielsweise beim giro d'italia in den
90er jahren schon im finale im absoluten
finale 500 meter vor dem ziel waren die
absperrgitter deutlich höher
deutlich solider und na ja wenn du dir
dann mit plexiglas belegt wären dann
wäre das so ein bisschen wie danke aber
ich glaube die schwere des unfalls liegt
vor allen dingen daran dass diese
absperrgitter auseinander geflogen sind
dann auch in das fahrerfeld hinein
das wäre der erste punkt und dann muss
man natürlich auch darüber nachdenken
ist so eine bergab sprint ankunft
überhaupt sinnvoll sprich 70 80
stundenkilometer dazu erreichen dass das
seit einigen jahren bei der
polen-rundfahrt müsste man vielleicht
auch die veranstalter in die pflicht
nehmen
strecken minimal anzupassen da und dann
vielleicht auch menschen die die fahrt
linie verlassen spricht braucht glaubt
er an der mittellinie anfängt zu spinnen
und dann so nach rechts rüber fährt weil
das weil da jemand kommt die im
reglement schon ganz klar
als zurücksetzte sprich wenn sie dich
damit bin werden sie dann trotzdem
gewonnen haben das sind so die drei
sachen die man jetzt im augenblick
vielleicht anvisieren könnte und was man
auch anvisieren kann ist natürlich dem
war wieder alles gute zu wünschen und
irgendwo wegen der mann jetzt hier sieht
natürlich hat den fehler gemacht aber
das ist vielleicht auch das ende seiner
karriere durch ja ja ja vielleicht nie
mehr zu alter leistung zurück kommen wie
viele andere auch also es ist schon auch
psychologisch für alle beteiligten ganz
lustig
vielen dank marcel wie ist ihre
einschätzung dankeschön